et là bas après leur entrevue jacques
chirac et le secrétaire général des
nations unies ont fait une très courte
déclaration à la presse le président
français a d'abord commencé à dire qu'il
répétait les conditions posées à l'irak
dans cette négociation
j'appelle en tous les cas
l'irak a accepté les propositions qui
lui seront faites par le secrétaire
général de l'onu
car ce sont par réalité les propositions
de la communauté internationale tout
entière et je sais que monsieur kofi
annan fera de son mieux pour préserver
la paix j'espère que chez soi position
de convaincre sa des présidences adam
breen d'accepter cet impôt position cash
différent d éviter qu il ya une frappe
militaire